>>Chris Kelly: I'll give you guys
a short overview of your choices.
You then will go into the survey
and figure out what's going
to be the best use of your time.
Once I get your info, then we'll be
able to figure out what the geography
of the room is going to be.
>>By having access to lots of different
sources of data I'm able to set students
up with learning situations
in which no student feels
like they are over-challenged
or feels like they're way ahead
and there's nothing of value.
In short, the student's time
has purpose and allows them
to be able to reach mastery.
>>Penelope Pak McMillen: Here at Summit
we serve a wide range of students
and we want to make sure that the
expectations are exactly the same
for students, regardless of their
background or their prior preparation.
In order for us to be effective
educators we need to see real-time data
to ensure that the way
that I am spending my time
as a teacher is actually
meeting the goals
of all the kids that
are in my classroom.
>>Chris Kelly: So, in terms of
choices, and this has a lot to do
with the survey I sent out
yesterday around office hours,
about half of you said that
you wanted a lesson on skills.
>>I do remember my own
high school experience.
If I was ahead I'm thinking
to myself, "How am I going
to kill fifty-five minutes?"
And if I was behind, I felt frustrated
and I felt like I was wasting my time
because I wasn't getting the
support or the help I needed.
So, a survey can give you
really valuable information
about what those needs
so you can meet them.
>>You guys can go ahead and go into
your Chromebooks, go to your email,
and then there is the Day 7 survey.
>>Kayla: At the beginning of
every class we take a survey
and it just helps us determine where we
are in the project and then he'll set
up workshops and places for people to go
based on where they are on the survey.
>>Penelope Pak McMillen:
It could be a Google survey
or a quick thumbs up-thumbs
down to a mini-quiz to ensure
that we actually know what
our kids need that day
and that we are giving them
exactly what they need.
>>Cady Ching: You are going
to write three different facts
that you could include in a introduction
paragraph for this lab report.
You guys have two minutes and thirty
seconds to come up with three things.
Pass those sheet of papers forward.
>>Knowing where every single student
is at all times in the day allows me
to deliver the support
that each child needs.
Some of the ways that I build
that into my classroom are
by doing pre-assessments in class.
So, the warm-up will be of an
activity that the students can fill out
and then I can just differentiate the
class based on those stacks of paper.
>>Cady Ching: So, if your name is in
a gray box I would like to guide you
through an annotation where
you check yourself to see
if you have all the information
required to get a seven.
Can I have you guys move now?
>>Armando: The teachers here
they always know where you're at,
so I think it's a great
thing that they could, like,
constantly see where your grades
are at, what you're struggling with.
If you need, like, help with a specific
grade, they could help you with that.
>>Penelope Pak McMillen: We have
an online platform where all
of the curriculum lives and
where students take assessments
that show their mastery.
It also gives the same
data to their teachers.
And, so, the teachers can use
the platform to make decisions
about how they want to use
their instructional time.
>>Cady Ching: Go ahead
and open you computers.
There's tons of other readings
that we uploaded into the PLP.
They're based on your reading level.
>>PLP stands for Personalized
Learning Plan
and the PLP tool is the technology
platform that students are using
to learn content to get
feedback and to complete work.
>>Cady Ching: So, you are ready for the
Level 5 or comparing and contrasting--
>>Students and teachers have access
to the same Google documents.
So, everything is real-time.
>>Chrystal: In the PLP is where we are
able to see our progress and our grades.
Because I'm able to request feedback,
I'm able to understand what I need to do
in order to improve my grade.
And I'm also able to see where I'm
going to be on track and, like,
what I need to do in order
to be more on top of my work.
>>Cady Ching: I'm able to know
where they are and further,
I can deliver that message about
how they're doing in class,
what they need to work
on, so much more quickly
than I could before the use of the plan.
>>Chris Kelly: With all these different
data streams that I've got coming in,
whether it's the survey or a PLP, I've
got access to information that allows me
to set students up with the learning
situations, with the sorts of choices
that they need to make in order
to get a first-class education.
>>Penelope Pak McMillen: So, I think the
most important thing that we do here is
to ensure that our teaching is
personalized to really build outcomes
that are appropriate to your
learners and create an action plan
where your feedback is
meeting them where they are at
and pushing them to where
they need to go.
>>Cady Ching: Chairs up.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
>>Student: Thank you!
>>Cady Ching: Bye!